[Music]
hey everybody my name is Oscar this I'm
joined today by David Jewett hello I've
called you David I don't know why
no names Dave yeah we're here at e3 2018
and dave we've been to check out sukira
shadows die twice hell yeah
the new game from From Software of Dark
Souls blood-borne Demon Souls Fame tell
me about it is it is it gonna be is it
gonna satisfy Dark Souls fans it's I
think it's gonna satisfy an itch to die
cause fans and blood-borne fans have but
it is very much its own beast like how
blood-borne was like a distant cousin to
Dark Souls this game is like long-lost
family member found on ancestry.com it's
it's very different they've got things
like there's much more verticality in
the game which is one thing that that
will be immediately noticeable where is
this you're much more agile you can so
it's worth going back back a step from
that verticality but you've got you've
only got one arm yeah it's been replaced
by what was called this shinobi
prosthetic which is one of the coolest
names for an ability in a game it's
really what we know the game starts you
are I think these are final names but
you are the shinobi and you are the
protector of the Lord and you arm gets
caught off by the rival and he takes the
Lord away so your mission is to save the
Lord get revenge they were very light on
story details but like I said you you
lose your army gets replaced by this
should no be prosthetic the first thing
you use it for is this this verticality
so you can get onto rooftops get into
tree you've got like a grappling hook
right yeah so that that immediately
makes it extremely different to many
souls borne games but also it's kind of
like a multi-tool you can switch it and
turn it into a fan for defensive you can
turn it into an axe which is used to
break shields you can throw firecrackers
to distract enemies that one looked
really cool use it to ignite your sword
for a shuriken Zout of it it's what I've
done is they've they've taken like this
Osborn DNA but given you so many more
options so what I find interesting is
that enemies will be really hard to
fight as you know
it's a from software game of course they
are but they'll all have weaknesses that
you can exploit using this multi-tool
for what one example in the demo we saw
there was like there was a troll and
eventually it overpowered us but we
found out that using the the fire
crackers and the fire the troll was
afraid of it but you can find that out
in the game by overhearing conversations
and learning it's a wild like like Dark
Souls had environmental storytelling
like in the Drake bridge there's fire
everywhere else you should assume
there's a dragon coming I think that's
their way of doing this you can learn
about the world by overhearing stuff and
you've also got a sword as well we
should say is that yes shinobi that is
your your main source yeah I think if
Khan Miyazaki said the mission statement
for the combat of this game was clashing
of swords yeah and so like that's very
evident you can see this like this huge
flash when you do clash swords and it
happened just a lot it seems like
there's less emphasis on hits it feels
like from I got from Adem it feels like
enemies will die in two or three or four
hits yeah but it's so much harder to get
those hits through but when you when you
land them like blood Spurs I like its
proper Kill Bill blood like yeah and
when you when you do eventually defeat
an enemy they can come back to life and
so can you right yeah so part of the the
USP of this right yeah again like
Osbourne games you die you lose your
stuff this is very very different they
pay with their really secretive about
the mechanic but when you die you can
just revive yourself mmm
and usually when you die in these games
you're back to your bonfire apparentiy
there is another checkpoint system but
it again works in very differently and
we saw that the that the player died and
he was left on the ground and then the
enemies would walk away but he was able
to use like a power to resurrect himself
on the spot to then kind of reengage
stealth and get a stealth kill and again
like the the stealth mechanics there
according at light stuff that is
something new to these kind of games
yeah it plays into that element of
overhearing conversations the clashing
of swords thing because it's not going
to be so much like dodge dodge dodge
hide behind a shield you
gonna be able to take on too many
enemies so you need to use stealth to
kind of even the odds so like engage
from the rooftops jump down burst into
shadows it's not going to be a stealthy
game from what they were telling us
stealth is used to gain an upper hand
and engage in combat and that's what I
really like about the the whole death
and resurrection thing as well as that
they've basically said that the death
can be used to your advantage in this
like it death is a mechanic now it's not
just a failed state you can come back
you can that will reset enemy positions
or you can come back and try like you
said try and stealth them I think that's
a really really interesting yeah
mechanic and and it goes for enemies as
well we saw footage of a boss being
defeated and then him coming back with
two sort of shadow versions of himself
and you had to fight that boss again but
two of them yeah it's it's very
interesting I really really like the
direction they're going it feels like
this is it's definitely a combination of
stuff they've learned from previous
games but it's also like I said it's its
its own beast it's got its own DNA you
shouldn't really compare it to it's not
going to fit into the the souls born
like like Venn diagram it's going to sit
outside it's gonna be instantly
recognizable to fans of those games but
it's got like it's gonna have the same
darkness that these games are known for
but it's also got lots of light and
color and it's going to have similar
mechanics but it's also got so much more
and so many options so it's it's gonna
be hugely interesting to play and I'm
I'm super excited to go in and get
crushed by the first boss that phone
awesome
well goes for everything else secure
shadows die twice stay tuned to
games.com
[Music]